let's do what let's do one more quick
second before the super chat okay look
super here's a racist bro oh really
cool we re-examine how you portray cops
on screen now it's time to talk about
superheroes mylanta my friends my
friends I must tell you why I find this
this time'll time.com from Time magazine
yeah do you want to know why I love this
article do tell me so the argument is
superheroes tend to be white people
enforcing their vision of Justice on an
unwilling population and I was like and
you have a problem with that the article
says yes I'm like okay now do an Tifa oh
and there is a drawer of mostly white
people using violence to enforce their
vision of justice and an unwilling
populace aha I think it's funny that
they don't realize their view of an tyfa
is the same as this and they're
criticizing it for the same reason you
welcome to the club
you now understand why we don't like an
tyfa there is there is an issue with
superheroes being vigilantes yeah and
quite literally have you ever seen the
Batman movies where he fights cops no
it's true they don't get it they don't
understand that yes what they're doing
is not acceptable well to be fair the
Commissioner is okay with Batman yeah
you know but that the point is like
spider-man Batman and many superheroes
go against the grain
you know against the law but then you
have Superman who very much works within
the confines of law and the American Way
yeah they use Superman for this what was
Superman's like original motto truth
justice and the American Way
oh yeah oh yeah now that now they want
to complain about that interesting but
let's read let's read what time has to
say
oh good about how we portray cities and
they show this picture of everyone
touching Superman in the past several
weeks as calls to defund the police have
gone mainstream pop culture critics and
fans have reconsidered how Hollywood
hero wisest hero Isis never heard of
legal legal procedurals and procedurals
and shoot-'em-ups action movies have
long presented a skewed perception
of the justice system in America to be
fair we just watched all the Pirates
movies recently like you're hanging out
ya know weekend and like I played all
the Pirates yeah it's great pirates are
really awful things yeah they're they're
like murderous rapists yeah tell you my
story about dealing with the land
pirates oh Elgin oh really
yeah no what happened so me and Isha
were driving through and we were driving
around Europe and we stopped in Belgium
and we were actually warned about this
before we we left about land pirates
this is a real thing my hand pilot so
what they do is they they look for RVs
all right at like different places and
they gasp because all RVs have a like an
exhaust spot that has to be it's legally
you have to have an openness of the area
so the air can flow so they gas the
inside of the RV put the people to sleep
break into the RV and steal everything
and then leave oh and then you wake up
and it's all gone so we're cooking
dinner we're you know we're night owls
to work up late and we we were looking
out the window and she's like I see
someone looking at us and I'm like what
I look out and there sure enough there's
a dude like spying on our RV I'm like
okay so I kind of like turn the light on
and I'm like I look at him I'm like I
see you and I see and he like Oh walks
away and I'm like now now we're on high
alert you know like we're eating dinner
we're looking out the window like what's
going on what's going on and we see them
go to another RV on the other side it
was like an RV spot and we're like oh my
gosh
that was the old couple I was walking
their dog like an hour ago and they're
in the RV right now and those guys and
then we hear a machine kick over and I'm
like oh my gosh they're probably gassing
these people so so I straight up get out
and I walk over and they are and I'm
like yo sorry if that was loud but
that's what I did I did I did you know
just like yeah yeah and they they don't
even look they're just like whatever
continuing and I'm like okay this is
this is weird so I go I go to the
nearest store I'm like yo there's some
there's some like land pirates and
they're like so English English and I'm
like
okay hello pirate what can I do you know
so I'm yes I like walk out and I go and
turn on and I we bounced it we are like
we're out of here but I think to Wayne I
think me yelling woke the people up
because as I walked out of the place
they were screaming past me in the car
oh it was one of those slow mo mo
moments where I like looked I was like
oh my gosh that's them and they were
like that's the dude that yelled at us
keep going keep going keep going
I was like wow land pirates are thing so
yes pirates are bad they steal your
stuff nice a nice side Dory
there's a mini quest random side so so
anyway the point is they as they're
talking about how movies make heroes out
of cops yeah they also made heroes out
of pirates in that movie that's good
like he's a pirate and a good man no
pirates literally like you're on a boat
three months your entire life is on the
boat they shoot cannons at you your your
whole world is burning down your bottle
the boat yeah they didn't leave you for
dead take all the goods and leave and
take the women yep they take the women
that's why they don't like pirates but
this movie made all the Pirates really
fun great heroes but they were like
anti-heroes I guess those were Disney
pirates so maybe kids we can get away
did you imagine like all these kids
being like I want to be a pirate and
they're like they got wow you did that
they've got fake eye patches and they're
going on huh they're like swinging at
each other and then you have like
there's actual pirates that exist today
and like have you seen that video from
the cargo ship and the Pirates attack it
oh yeah and then they're like shooting
at them like crazy
yep yep Somali pirates I think oh man
they're crazy anyway the point of
bringing up is movies make heroes of
whatever they want to make heroes out of
you know including bad guys that's what
I was talking about the other day about
how people are seeing movies and going
that's what real life is like you know
it must be like that there must be that
kind of person
everywhere that's what everyone's like
they like turn I'll always the the
antagonist of the movie that's what
everyone that doesn't agree with me is
like now these people are mentally on
like this proves it to me have you ever
watched Law & Order SV
you a couple episodes I think it's a
great show good show and Elliot Stabler
one of the characters on the show okay
detective mm-hmm and I think he is I
don't think he's a bad guy but he does
have his moments where he's a bad guy
where he'll like he like look they're
dealing with sex crimes and stuff
okay so there's moments where he liked
they catch a pedo and he snaps and like
just starts beating the crap out of the
guy and I'm like I feel you dude it's
like I can't but Natalie be upset
because you're I mean actually I'm
watching it's like yeah yeah mom Kim
yeah one of the issues is that on
several occasions he gets the wrong guy
mm-hmm sui ends up beating up innocent
people in his rage but he gets in
trouble for it this is what they don't
understand about pals accountable yes
they make cops heroes but in the show
they're like stable or you're you
suspended or whatever like you can't do
that what's wrong with you man there's
actually one cop in the show who I think
actually goes to jail no because because
of a brutality you know issue and I'm
like the support of the show you know it
reminds me of like when that when with
all the feminist talk about rape culture
stuff they're like we have a society
that glorifies it and I was like where
you do because quite literally we have a
TV show that's been on for like 20 years
dedicated to talking about why this is
illegal and a crime and evil and these
people must be in prison yeah it's it's
it's an insane to think that a society
glorifies this when it actually
glorifies a female sergeant named Olivia
Benson who leads a team to stop these
people and it's a highly rated show this
show is great I love it take the bad
guys down man nobody's supporting this
so when you get Superman who doesn't go
against the government and works with
them I'm sorry man you're not you're
sure and what would you prefer is are
you are you would you want Pirates of
the Caribbean where the bad guys are the
good guys who go against the government
and get or Superman where the good guy
works at the government because you get
both so articles like this in my opinion
it's just here's what I think happened
there's some woke millennial you know
sitting in the office at a time HQ in
New York mm-hmm and their boss comes in
and says I'm seeing a lot of stories
about these cops being bad and like
Hollywood can you write something like
that and then the well person is like um
I mean Oh spider-man's white you know
maybe we could do something with
uh yeah let me think of something and
then it's like oh yeah hey superheroes
are just basically cops but like alright
then up something they just make up the
last minute because someone's like hey
I'll make it even worse actually the
editor walks in and says yo look you got
to publish something just I don't know
pull something out of a hat and then he
was okay and he goes um let's see
police brutality locust and Superman can
I do with that ooh I know
superheroes are are glorified and
they're criminals let's talk about
superhero reform you know it's
interesting though yeah I was reading I
was reading something real interesting
about superheroes and it was saying
something like this might have been
Jordan Peterson actually how early hero
archetypes challenged the system okay
like I can't remember which story but
like Hercules I guess you know or
whatever they would fight the gods and
challenge the gods and all that stuff
and now today they uphold the system the
heroes maintain the status quo hmm and
like when did that switch happen when
did it used to be that the powers that
be were the bad guys and now you know
the powers that be are supported by the
superheroes it's interesting very
officing someone said in chat that the
sjw's cancelled SVU they did and I was
like like what's going on to this and it
really it's not that I haven't seen that
it is cancelled but I guess people are
trying to cancel Olivia Benson the main
character why because she's a cop I
don't know it doesn't know the first
article that I come up with this say
goodbye to Law & Order it says it does
wonderful Olivia Benson gets lionized
as televisions good cop that does
real-world damage dude a strong female
it's all burning down around us I don't
even have that good enough so what what
happens let's looks like let's say Trump
wins what happens you know like cops are
bad up is down the the virus is is
healing black lives matter supporters I
don't even know what's going on anymore
no no no this what's going on right now
is I'm becoming politically aware I'm
not gonna lose that right next year
this isn't going away I'm I am here now
I I can't go back I will never go back
I want to know what's going on what's
going on right now is everyone's getting
that way everyone's looking for
themselves they're like maybe not
everyone clearly no but no I did not
some people at time.com no but I you
know I feel that I feel like people are
seeing in there like you know what my
I'm gonna be more politically active I'm
gonna be I'm gonna get into politics a
lot of people have been hitting me up on
Twitter saying like you know what you've
inspired me to get into politics and I'm
like yes so great thank you we need to
wait what is the word hero hero sighs
hero why did we need to hero eyes
politics and and it take down the
corrupt politicians that are really the
cause of all this stuff yeah you know
the issue is for too long we have been
comfortable what have I been saying oh
well had no reason to be involved
exactly and because of this the people
got elected were manipulators deceivers
and exploiters you know and then when
things started to get stagnant and bad
and scary and freaky people started to
come back actually saying like I gotta
fix these things mm-hmm and so now
you've quite literally got a very small
group of real people who are like let's
fix it with giant swamp swamp creatures
yep no about yeah it's true it's it's
because there's people out there that
want the power and when you have all of
the authority in the hands of the people
that just want the power that's when the
issues that's where we're at now yep all
the people in Nancy Pelosi for example
she wants that power she wants to be on
on the king of her castle look at her
chin she represents these Democrats have
been in office for decades who are
complaining about the state of the world
because Trump has been in office for
three years they're lying
a trumpet is so bad at this is like but
you've been here for 50 years yeah
you're not fishing anything Joe you were
actually in the vice presidency for
eight years right we didn't fix any of
this you made it all worse you did worse
all of the riots all the complaints
about stop and frisk and police
brutality started under you dude so why
would I want to go back to that I don't
I don't know I don't know if Trump is
better but I know you're certainly not
I was entertaining voting for one of
these Democrats until they picked Biden
yeah I was like that's it I'm done not
that guy you're nuts absolutely insane I
was watching those debates next to you
and I was just sitting there like what
am i what am I doing with these what are
these people actually talking they want
Trump to win back to it I know I said it
as a joke but the more we talk about it
the more I make the real conspiracy I
don't know Trump Trump's pretending to
be the underdog fighting the machine but
he's actually the real Emperor yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you